the wall stood worldwide for an
inhuman border that fires the europe of
freedom from europe of the dictatorship
and with it the people who
belong together we look to berlin with hope today
[music]
the will for freedom of
the germans in east berlin in the gdr wall and barbed wire
peacefully  overcome
after almost three decades of separation
, people in germany celebrated a celebration
of reunion of
togetherness of unity
[music]
each of us feels these days
that what i have now received in
europe are events of historical significance, especially in central, eastern and
south-eastern
europe
for the first time since the end of the second world war, there
is reason to
hope that the west-east
conflict will be overcome
for lasting stability in common
freedom for the whole of europe
Germany can only complete it if
we push ahead with the unification of our old continent
. The construction of a united Europe is above
all a work of peace
and we must do this together because we must
rely on the same strength, even
when it comes to our vision of a
European peace order
everywhere  borders are
crossed unhindered where ideas and opinions are
freely exchanged and where people
can come together
distrust and enmity
have no chance in the long run
that applies to us in the federal republic of
germany that obviously
applies to the germans in the gdr and their
freedom ladies and gentlemen it goes
as well as the freedom of the
poles, the contact and the future of the people in
the soviet union, the future of
the private drawing of the bulgarians and
romanians, it's about the freedom of
one europe
[applause]
[music]